BACTERIA ARE TINY ONE-CELLED
ORGANISMS WITH THEIR OWN DNA.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DIVIDE, GROW,
AND, AS IS BEAUTIFULLY AND
TERRIFYINGLY SHOWN HERE, EVOLVE.
Narrator:
BECAUSE WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE
IS HOW THE PETRI DISH
IS DIVIDED INTO ZONES
HOLDING INCREASING STRENGTHS
OF ANTIBIOTICS...
THAT STILL CAN'T STOP
THE BACTERIA.
DO NOT MESS WITH
SINGLE-CELLED ORGANISMS.
Narrator: THIS IS THE WORK
OF HARVARD MED RESEARCHERS
MICHAEL BAYM, TAMI LIEBERMAN,
AND ROY KISHONY.
BUT HOW ARE THEIR BACTERIA
BEATING THE ANTIBIOTIC?
IN THIS EXPERIMENT,
REGULAR E. COLI BACTERIA
ARE PLACED AT THE VERY ENDS
OF A GIANT PETRI DISH.
NOW, THERE'S NO
ANTIBIOTICS THERE,
BUT EVERY FEW INCHES,
INCREASING CONCENTRATIONS
OF ANTIBIOTICS ARE ADDED
SO THAT RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE,
THERE IS 1,000 TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF ANTIBIOTICS
REQUIRED TO KILL THE E. COLI.
THE BACTERIA,
WHICH APPEAR WHITE,
GROW UNTIL THEY ENCOUNTER
A ZONE OF ANTIBIOTICS
THAT STOPS THEM.
BUT THEN YOU SEE ONE
OF THE COLONIES OF BACTERIA
WILL START GROWING
INTO THAT ZONE
BECAUSE IT HAS EVOLVED
RESISTANCE TO THAT ANTIBIOTIC.
Narrator:
HOW DO BACTERIA EVOLVE?
Krishna-Pillay: THEY REPRODUCE
BY GETTING BIG ENOUGH
TO MAKE A COPY OF THEMSELVES.
THE IDEA IS THAT THAT NEW COPY
IS EXACTLY THE SAME
AS THE FIRST ONE,
BUT IT DOESN'T ALWAYS
WORK LIKE THAT.
THERE'S ALWAYS A CHANCE
THAT YOU'LL HAVE
SOME KIND OF GENETIC MUTATION
THAT MAKES YOU
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
TO THE FIRST BACTERIAL CELL.
Ruben: THIS ABILITY
TO MULTIPLY QUICKLY,
DURING WHICH THEIR OFFSPRING
ARE ESSENTIALLY TRYING OUT
THE SUCCESS OR FAILURE
OF DIFFERENT RANDOM MUTATIONS,
ALLOWS THE BACTERIA
TO EVOLVE VERY FAST.
THIS IS EVOLUTION IN ACTION.
WE SEE THIS OVER AND OVER
AS THE BACTERIA GROW TOWARDS
THE CENTER OF THE PLATE.
Krishna-Pillay: THIS IS
A FANTASTIC ILLUSTRATION
OF WHY WE SHOULDN'T
OVERUSE ANTIBIOTICS.
EVERY TIME WE TAKE ANTIBIOTICS,
WE'RE EXPOSING BACTERIA TO THEM.
AND EVERY TIME WE DO THAT,
THEY'RE EVOLVING
TO DEAL WITH IT.